so
[Music]
[Music]
in my last video i was doing my best to
slow down in santa fe new mexico
in reality i spent most of my time
organizing the van preparing taxes and
finishing up some photography work
when the time finally came to relax
nathaniel and i were pitched a
last-minute job by mazda to shoot the
new cx-50 in santa barbara california
the offer was too good to pass up so
before we knew it we were back on the
west coast making our way south from los
angeles to the hotel california in santa
barbara california
this is home sweet home for the next
couple days
so beautiful
this trip to california was more than a
month ago and i've filmed two or three
new videos since then
it's been interesting sharing my life in
such a delayed and public way
when i sit down to edit i'm usually
looking at six to eight weeks of footage
very little which makes any sense when
dropped together into a timeline
different days different moods different
places a sunset here dinner there
i watch each clip one by one wondering
what is the story here
is there a story
sometimes there is and sometimes there
isn't
it's 10 p.m
tomorrow's kind of a full day because
we're gonna go shooting and then we have
a mountain biking event which we're
doing as a group and then we have a big
group dinner so
yeah it's going to be pretty full on and
this
shower is
definitely nicer than what i have in my
van which is nothing so
so
[Music]
[Music]
cheers
out
let's go
it's 5 16 a.m
we're a little bit behind but uh
i think we're gonna make it up for
sunrise no problem
[Music]
sound gets in your bones
everybody driving under
love's not a destination
i think it's a journey home
so what if mine is on the lonely road
what
[Music]
that's the sound of my one and only in
the distance
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right first light has hit
and we just shot some layers out there
getting a shot
back to the old horizon
influencers in the wild
[Music]
we just ordered room service and we're
taking some story content because it's
all part of the experience
look at that toast i'm so excited to eat
this some bts of
what we do
[Music]
my mind tends to wander to whatever's
right in front of me and whatever's
happening right now
so sometimes i struggle when creating
these videos
[Music]
and pretending to be present a moment
that's already passed
but it's also teaching me to be patient
to reflect and take note of all the
beautiful roads this life has led me
down
[Music]
[Applause]
as i'm editing this video i'm actually
camped out in utah in the middle of
nowhere
the irony of editing this footage of
cocktail parties rooftop dinners and
nights spent in an 800 hotel room all
while actually sitting in the middle of
the desert
hot sweaty going on day six without a
shower and wearing the same dirty
clothes i've worn literally for the past
three days
sometimes it feels like i'm living a
double life
always existing at the extreme end of
things
from sleeping in the back of my suv to
house-sitting million-dollar homes from
living on room service and five-star
hotels to sleeping in the backcountry
and cooking stale ramen we made it
into the car
that was a whirlwind of packing and
running
no more room service for us
i like to think the constant change
keeps me flexible and open-minded
but
i don't really know if nothing else one
thing is for sure
it's always an adventure and pretty much
never boring
[Music]
we had a lot of editing to do for the
monster project so we booked an airbnb
out near the mountains and
stayed still for a few days while a big
storm rolled through
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
taos reminded me of just how much i love
thunderstorms
especially in the mountains
the sense of rain
the warm wind the way the light dances
with the dark
i was reminded of when i was little and
dreamed of being a storm chaser
who knows
maybe i still do
[Music]
later that week we met up with some
friends in taos and spent a few days
catching up that's pretty cool
we're just outside of taos and we're
doing hike
through some hot springs
with nathaniel ann and clint
let's say it's high free eye
this place is beautiful
[Music]
you know the polaris
[Music]
the coolest thing
[Music]
mariah nate and i camped out in the
house together for a few days and i
filmed absolutely nothing
except for a few short clips here and
there we spent most of our time just
hanging out living life
after a few shared campfires some deep
talks and really long walks we set our
see you laters and headed back out onto
the road
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
holy crap is so windy
i am fighting to keep my
van in between the lines here this road
is crappy
and the wind is intense
and it's been like this for the past
i don't know
hour and a half
what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and this is where i'll leave you
parked on a cliff edge in the middle of
the windstorm
heading in tonight
i'll see you next time
thanks for being here